we're told that lisa tried to solve an
equation see 42 is equal to 6a or 6
times a
and then we can see her steps here and
they say where did lisa make her first
mistake so pause this video and see if
you can figure that out and it might be
possible she made no mistakes
all right
well we know she ends up with seven
equals six which is sketchy so let's see
what happened here
so right over here it looks like well
she did something a little bit strange
she divided the left hand side by 6 and
the right hand side by a you don't want
to divide two sides of an equation by
two different things then it's no longer
going to be an equation the equality
won't hold
an algebraically legitimate thing is to
do the same thing to both sides but she
didn't do it here so this is where she
made her first mistake let's give
another example here
so here it says that jin tried to solve
an equation all right x plus 4.7 is
equal to 11.2 where did jin make his
first mistake pause this video and try
to figure it out
all right so it looks like in order to
isolate the x on the left hand side jin
is subtracting 4.7 from the left
and then
also subtracting 4.7 from the right
so that is looking good doing the same
thing to both sides subtracting 4.7 from
both sides
and then over here on the left hand side
these two would cancel so you'd be left
with just an x
and let's see 11.2 minus 4.7
11.2
minus 4
would be
7.2
and then minus the 0.7 would be 6.5 so
this is where jyn
made his mistake on the calculating part
let's do another example this is a lot
of fun
so here we are told that marina tried to
solve an equation and we need to figure
out where marina made her first mistake
all right 1 6 is equal to two-thirds y
so the first step
or the first thing that marina did right
over here is to multiply both sides of
this equation by the reciprocal of
two-thirds which is three-halves
multiplied the left-hand side by
three-halves multiplied the right-hand
side by three-halves which is a very
reasonable thing to do we're doing the
same thing to both sides multiplying by
three-halves
and then when we go over here let's see
three halves times one sixth
we we could divide the numerator and the
denominator by three so it's going to be
one over two so that indeed is going to
be one half times one half which is one
fourth so that checks out and on this
side if you multiply three halves times
two thirds that's going to be one so
this checks out so it actually looks
like marina did everything correctly so
no mistake
no mistake
for marina
let's do one last example
so here taylor is trying to solve an
equation and so where did taylor first
get tripped up
n minus 2.7 is equal to 6.7 in order to
isolate this n over here i would add 2.7
to both sides
but that's not what taylor did
taylor subtracted 2.7 from both sides
so the first place that taylor starts to
trip up or move in the wrong direction
is right over here
now what taylor did is not algebraically
incorrect you would end up with n minus
5.4
is
equal to 4 but it's not going to help
you solve this equation you just replace
this equation with another equivalent
equation that is no simpler than the one
before and then of course instead of
getting n minus 5.4 equals four taylor
calculated incorrectly as well but where
they first started to get tripped up or
at least not move in the right direction
would be right over here